foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this new
video I will be discussing everything
that will happen and how so the Dragon
season 1 finale on this Sunday if you do
not want to know what will be happening
in the final episode I would highly
recommend shutting off this video right
now as you all know we're now only days
away from finally seeing how the dance
of the Dragons will begin most of us
have been waiting to see this ever since
we first heard HBO was developing this
show back when Game of Thrones was
airing its final season over three years
ago in this video I want to go over
every major scene that will happen in
the final episode if you saw HBO's
official new video after the most recent
episode aired then you know the season 1
finale will begin with renero finding
out about her father's death as well as
aegon's coronation now according to this
leak it will be Damon Targaryen who
informs rhaenyra about this information
the shocking revelations will send
rhaenyra into labor and she will
unfortunately lose her daughter not only
does she lose the baby but she also
finds out it's malformed very similar to
what happened to daenerys's Baby in the
first season of Game of Thrones shortly
after this a funeral was held for
renera's daughter who she had named
vicenio now if you've read Fire and
Blood then you know this event sends
rhaenyra into a black Fury and she vows
to defeat her enemies and get back what
is rightfully hers it doesn't say
whether or not this happens here but I
have to imagine it will it also says
Damon will use his Dragon caraxis to
force the kingsguard on Dragonstone into
swearing fealty for renero afterwards
she has given her father's Crown which
we have seen in photos already one of
the Cargill Brothers of the kingsguard
who fled King's Landing with rhaenys
will bend his knee and give viserys's
Crown to renero then we will see them
hold their first black council meeting
we've already seen several photos of
this as well in raniera's Black council
is Damon rhaenys Lord Corliss valerion
rhaenyra's Sons Jason Luke as well as
her new members of the kingsguard they
will be holding these black Council
meetings in the same location on
Dragonstone where we've seen Stannis and
Daenerys in Game of Thrones now during
this episode Serato will arrive on
Dragonstone with what he believes is a
generous offer for winero it will say if
she bends her knee and accepts aegon as
her new king they will allow her to be
the lady of Dragonstone and her son
lucari's will be given drift Mark It
also says Serato will hand her something
from Alison it's from one of the history
books they were reading in the first
episode this is a reminder that rhaenyra
and ellisent were former friends it does
look like this scene is happening in
HBO's official video once again we do
see Damon in Serato in a standoff while
it looks like renera is standing right
in the middle of them while holding this
letter in her hand you can see she's
also wearing her father's crown on her
head later in the episode it does say
runira will consider the offer instead
of losing thousands of lives as well as
many dragons rhaenyra says they should
focus on the threat that lies in a North
Beyond the Wall this will make Damon
Furious because no one has said anything
about it before it says he will then
walk out onto the beach of Dragonstone
and release a lifetime of emotion that
must be what's happening in the set
photos right here it does look like he's
very emotional in these photos and this
scene hasn't been in any of the episodes
yet eventually we will see Laura Corliss
valerion recover from his injury
suffered in battle rainey's will let him
know about everything that happened
while he was away he will swear fealty
to renera and join her black Council
renera will then inform her sons about
the offer from King's Landing her son
Jace will say the greens will not honor
them for very long this is when they
decide they will need more allies on her
side as of right now Lady Jane Aaron of
the veil Lord Stark of Winterfell and
Lord Baratheon of storm Zen have yet to
swear fealty to either side raniera's
Sons Jason Luke will volunteer to go to
these houses on Dragon back in hopes of
winning them over for their mother as
you all know she will need all the help
she can get that's when Rainer will
reluctantly agree to let them go so long
as they go as envoys only she does not
want them entering the fight renera then
gives her son Luke one last hug before
he leaves Dragonstone we will then see
Damon go into the cave on Dragonstone
where Verma Thor has made his home Damon
will sing to the dragon in high valyria
and he lets Verma Thor know he will find
him a new Rider we have also seen
several photos of this scene as well now
in one of the greatest sequences of this
season rhaenyra's son lucari's will
arrive at Storm's end the home of house
Baratheon when he does arrive he will
see amond and vegar are already there as
a matter of fact Amon has already been
there for days making Fast Friends with
Laura Baratheon during this scene amond
will demand an eye for an eye and we
will see that Amon now has a sapphire in
his eye socket now before any blood is
shed under Lord baratheon's roof he
stops the boys from fighting he will
make little lucari's leave but
unfortunately for him Amon will will not
be far behind exactly how it's described
in George R Martin's Fire and Blood
there's an incredible lightning and
thunderstorm right outside of the castle
over shipbreaker Bay now because
lucarius has a very small Dragon he's
actually a lot swifter than vegar as a
matter of fact he might have even
outflown vegar if the weather was much
better however as you can see in HBO's
photos and videos the weather will be a
major issue for Lou carries and his
Dragon vegar will snap his dragon's neck
in half before swallowing lucari's hole
when the news of this gets back to
Dragonstone it's Damon who reveals it to
Romero now if she doesn't go into a
black Fury after losing her newborn
daughter then she will definitely after
this the fun and games are all over as
soon as someone's son gets slaughtered
like lucarius does here now there's also
a few notes that say Jace's scene will
not be until the second season we will
not see him fly or land at the veil or
Winterfell in the final episode they are
saving this scene for the first episode
of the second season they still have to
find actors for Lady Jane Aaron and Lord
Kragen Stark well there you have it
ladies and gentlemen this is how the
first season will end let me know if you
think House of the Dragon lives up to
your expectations or not I think this
final scene of aemond and vegar is a
great way of ending the first season I
can't believe we're finally about to see
it get brought to life from what I've
seen in HBO's photos and videos it does
look incredible already it more or less
looks exactly how I imagined it while
reading the scene from Fire and Blood
let me know what all of you think down
below remember even after the first
season is over I will be making videos
during the entire off season while
everyone else goes on Hiatus during the
off-season I will be here releasing
videos for the foreseeable future like
I've said before I will be here until
the very end as always I want to thank
all of you for showing love and watching
my videos I hope all of you have a great
day I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you